can i tell you that so many content
creators when they get started are so
worried that it's gonna fail
but the difference between the people
that are succeeding and the people that
do not start
is the point of starting like they
succeed because they just kept going
it's a new year full of new
opportunities and new possibilities and
maybe a new youtube channel but if
you've been hesitant to getting started
this is the podcast for you if you've
been a part of the think media community
and you've maybe been watching some of
our youtube videos or listening to the
podcast but you haven't made the leap to
actually starting i hope that this
message encourages you my name is
heather torres and i'm the host of the
think media podcast the number one
podcast to help you grow your influence
on youtube and then turn that influence
into a high income and a high impact
online business i am so fired up because
we are kicking off the year here at
think media with our free 5 day youtube
1k challenge now this challenge is going
to help you learn how to get to your
first 1000 subscribers and earn your
first 1 000 on youtube we're gonna be
breaking it down over five whole days of
free content just for you to help you
kick start your year you can register at
tube1kchallenge.com
now if you're brand new to this podcast
i want to welcome you welcome to the
think media family you can subscribe if
you're watching on youtube or you can
subscribe wherever you're listening to
this content on we deliver a brand new
fresh podcast to you every single
tuesday as well as bonus episodes that
happen over on our youtube channel and
some episodes hit the podcast on the
listening app so make sure you are
following us all over the web to get all
of the current conversations we have
here on the podcast
[Music]
now i remember several years ago when i
was first starting my youtube channel
and i can tell you that the girl you see
sitting here right now or listening to
on this audio was not the girl a few
years ago i was so scared when it came
to actually starting my youtube channel
i actually didn't even think i was
worthy enough to put content out on
youtube now i had been working behind
the camera for several years in the
digital marketing space but i was
actually too scared to press record i
waited three years before i put my first
video out online that was three years of
thinking about it contemplating learning
about the different pieces about video
but every single time i wanted to press
record i let fear hold me back and so
today i'm going to be breaking down some
of the things i had to do to push
through the fear to face everything and
rise so that i could get to the point i
am today where i can sit down and make
content well i'll mess up a hundred
times while i'm recording this i still
can get in front of the camera with so
much more ease and so i want to just use
this opportunity today at the beginning
of this year where you and i are just
having a conversation where i can be one
of your best friends just speaking life
into you and helping you get started
because i can tell you that on the other
side of your comfort zone on the other
side of you worrying about what other
people are going to think on the other
side of you stepping out in faith and
actually doing the thing there's going
to be success on that side and while
it's going to be hard and while there
may be trials and why you might feel
like gosh is this for me i can tell you
that through perseverance through
dedication through actually putting in
the work you will see your youtube
channel start to grow so let's break
down three ways or three tips that i
have for you three things i had to do to
actually get started on youtube now my
first one it may seem simple and
actually all of these tips might seem
like heather okay i know these but i
just need to reiterate them to you i
need you to hear them again if you heard
them last year or two years ago or three
years ago because i'm hoping that this
time is the time that you take action i
hope that this time as you're hearing
this as you as you hear me telling you
these three very simple things to do
that i had to put into place
that it will be the catalyst for you
actually taking action so number one i
need you to make a plan
i need you to make a plan
i know it sounds crazy and and the plan
might start with i need to film my
youtube channel this friday or i need to
film my youtube video this friday
maybe the plan is i want to get my
camera ready and i know that sounds like
really really simple but even if you're
filming on your smartphone maybe you're
filming on your ipad maybe you're
filming with the camera that your
husband got you for christmas this year
because you said you wanted to start
youtube maybe the plan is you need to
start understanding the gear that you're
going to use now if you have a
smartphone and you've been making tick
tock videos or reels or you've been
filming your kids soccer games you
already know how to use a camera so i
hope that i can eliminate the fear that
you quote unquote don't know how let's
make a plan and get yourself started so
here's a couple things that i had to
write down when i started my youtube
channel
what do i need to learn this year to
make this a reality
what do you need to learn this year like
i said maybe it's the gear maybe you
need to understand like okay i need to
actually stand in front of the window
not with but with the window behind me
like that's something you should learn
maybe i need to learn like where should
the lapel microphone go if that's what
you're using maybe you need to learn
like what setting looks good like what
background looks good how should it make
the lighting look good maybe that's what
you need to learn or maybe something you
need to learn is like how do i actually
just get over my fears how do i get and
gain confidence maybe you need to put
down watching things like yellowstone or
the crown and you need to pick up a good
book by you know john maxwell or lisa
revere like maybe you need to actually
be feeding yourself with things that are
going to inspire you rather than filling
yourself with things that may not help
you get to your goals and i want to step
on your toes i like the crown i haven't
watched yellowstone yet but i'm excited
too but that's not maybe where you need
to be right now
if you want to do something new you've
got to try something new if you want to
do something different you've got to
change what you've been doing so i want
you to get out a piece of paper i want
you to get out a pen and i want you to
write down what do you need to learn
this year
in some future episodes that we have
coming up here on the podcast we're
going to be pulling back the curtain and
sharing a little bit about what we do
here at think media how we prepare
ourselves how we prepare our team and
really what our themes are for the year
and one of the things that we challenge
each of our team members with is what
are you going to do to be at your best
what do you need to learn this year and
the second part of making a plan is
when are you going to make time now if
you know anything about heather torres
or think media you know that time
management is something that has
literally changed my life i know it
sounds crazy you're like really heather
a calendar changed your life yes
because when you start putting your
priorities first when you start putting
your dreams first when you start putting
on the calendar the things that you're
committing to yourself you'll start to
see change happen you know i really
think that like show me your calendar
and i'll show you where your priorities
are you don't have a calendar okay what
are we doing with your life we need to
get a calendar we need to start
understanding what are we doing with the
precious minutes that we have can i tell
you that tomorrow is not promised that
today is a day that you can take action
so when you look back six months from
now and you're like nothing's changed
well did you actually put in the work
when are you making time to do the thing
i know you might be working a full-time
job i know you might have kids at home i
know you might be
caring for maybe an elderly parent or or
maybe you have more than one job
but can i tell you that there are still
minutes in your day that you can be
devoting to your future
if you're just going through every
single day the same and not actually
making progress
then please don't look at me a year from
now and say heather i don't know what
happened i'm telling you every minute
matters so when are you going to do this
and then lastly in the makeup plan what
is your education plan i am a huge
proponent of books it could be audio
books it could be books that you're
actually physically reading but i want
to challenge you that if you have not
opened up a book
in the last year this is your year
this is the year that you're going to
get back into learning now as a
homeschool mom i can tell you that that
that people actually don't read books
after high school actually a study was
done that over 60 of people after
college never read a book again
what what are we doing we need to be in
a learning stage so i want to challenge
you that if you've not picked up a book
what's your first book now here at think
media we actually did our favorite books
that you can read so i'll make sure to
link that as a resource down below
because we'll offer you some of the best
books that have really helped us in
things like leadership in marketing and
understanding youtube in personal growth
and development and for me the bible so
i want you to be picking up a book this
year and on your plan deciding what am i
going to read now i don't know if you
know this about me but i actually have
dyslexia and so reading has been
something that i've struggled with my
entire life and so i figured out that
audiobooks were my thing and did you
know that you don't even have to buy
audiobooks you can get audio books for
free from your local library every
library has them you just have to
download the app on your phone or on
your tablet or on your computer and you
can get free audio books online
so i'm breaking down the barrier of
actually getting started when it comes
to making your plan number two i want
you to have a goal and when i say have a
goal i hope that the goal doesn't have
to do with artificial numbers right i
know that it'd be great to say well my
goal is to get to a hundred thousand
views or my goal is to get to you know
ten thousand dollars in my business but
i really want you when you're starting
your youtube channel to think about the
goal of being in the action not in the
result and that is a mindset shift when
it comes to doing youtube that's a
mindset shift when it comes to
uh
how we kind of operate in the world
everything is determined by a number and
and while inside of our free youtube
challenge we're gonna teach you how to
get to a thousand subscribers we're
gonna lay it out for you i want you to
write down your personal action goal
meaning how many videos do you plan to
get out this year
how many posts do you plan to put out on
your community tab how many hours do you
plan on spending inside of the community
returning comments or being involved in
different facebook groups online
how many hours how many outputs do you
plan to put in to making this happen
can i tell you a secret about youtube
the secret to growing on youtube is
posting videos on youtube i know it
sounds crazy but really in order to grow
a youtube channel you have to be
planting you have to actually put effort
in you have to grow
your channel and while there are magical
unicorns out there who are able to post
one video and get a million views that's
not
99.9 of people starting on the platform
you have to put in the work to learn how
to do this to over time start to grow
your channel we're going to teach you
the steps of how to do that but i want
you to actually have a goal
i recommend your goal be 52 videos this
year
that's one video per week that's all you
have to do to start to grow your channel
now the goal next year could be another
52 videos and then in two years you'll
have a hundred videos
in your youtube library
imagine what that's going to be like the
day when you have a hundred videos
in your youtube library
imagine the people's lives that are
going to be changed when you have 52
videos out this year
imagine what it's going to do for your
own self-confidence when you step
outside of your comfort zone and get in
front of the camera
imagine what it's going to be like when
a brand reaches out to you or you start
working with a company or you start
getting adsense and money is hitting
your bank account because of the effort
you put in on youtube this is possible
my friend you just have to make a plan
and have a goal
and then lastly
i want you to write this down i will not
let fear hold me back
i know it sounds hard
but fear is going to get in the way
it's going to be the thing that's going
to stop you
maybe you feel like this
i'm not good enough to do this heather
i actually i don't feel skilled enough
to do this what do i even have to offer
to the people on the internet
can i tell you that you have experiences
in life you probably already know
exactly the things that have helped you
move through this life that can help
other people
maybe you're already skilled in a
certain area maybe you have a degree in
something or maybe you've just been
working at a skill for a long time and
people want to learn how to do that
you are good enough for this and
actually no one has to give you
permission to even get started you have
to give yourself permission to mess up
in public
i know it sounds harsh but really it is
about messing up in public your first
videos they're gonna be your worst
videos
i know mine are when i look back at some
of my first videos my voice is up high
i'm i'm scared like crazy deer in the
headlights looking at the camera i
stumbled over my words a thousand times
it took me like 10 hours to edit my
first video i didn't even want to
publish it because i thought people are
gonna laugh at this i mean who am i to
be posting on the internet
can i tell you the coolest thing that's
happened
i have moms that come up to me now
crying
because they say your videos
unleash something in our family your
videos about about homeschooling about
just what your day looks like about the
curriculum that you're using helped our
kids understand that learning is fun
i can tell you that these are messy
videos but they are used to help people
and that's what you can do you're good
enough for this you don't need
permission to do this you can start
today after you listen to this podcast
you can grab your camera and you can
make your first video
maybe you think well it's not going to
be good enough
maybe you're already a professional i
see this happen a lot in people who are
very successful in something already
maybe you're a doctor or a lawyer or a
real estate agent or a hairdresser and
you've already established yourself in
this career and you're starting
something new
can i tell you that it's going to be
such a great humbling experience
to be at the beginning again you're
gonna have so much humility again for
those people who are coming into your
career field that are starting out fresh
and can i tell you that your experience
that you already have in one thing is
gonna help you accelerate in this thing
as well
it's gonna be okay
it doesn't have to be perfect but you
know what you need to bring to it
yourself
bring all of you bring your expertise
bring your funny jokes bring your
seriousness whatever that is it's going
to be okay it does not have to be
perfect you just have to make progress
and then number three you might be
thinking well i'm not really going to
start
because what if it fails
what if it fails
what if i put myself out there what if i
put hours into it what if i'm working on
the weekends on this thing and it
doesn't really go anywhere what if i
tell all my friends or i tell all my
colleagues or i tell all my family that
this is the new thing that i'm doing
and then it doesn't work
i want to turn that around for you this
year
i want you to think about this
what
if it succeeds
i mean if we thought about that like why
are we going to the negative right away
why don't we look to the positive think
about all of the skills you're going to
learn in the process
think about the the the willingness that
you're gonna have to push through those
uh icky feelings of like this is scary i
don't know what i'm doing the
self-confidence that you're gonna get on
the other side of actually doing it can
i tell you that so many content creators
when they get started are so worried
that it's gonna fail
but the difference between the people
that are succeeding and the people that
do not start
is the point of starting like they
succeed because they just kept going my
friend ben azani always says you gotta
suck
suck
suck to get to success
what if this succeeds
imagine what it's going to be like on
the other side of a year of dedication
to this
imagine what it's going to be like when
you can turn to your kids and say mom
was scared i didn't know what i was
doing but i started something and you
can too
what if it succeeds
you know so many times i hear people and
they go well i'm not good enough for
this i can't do that i don't really have
the things
and this year one of the things that i
want you to do that i had to do when i
first got when i first started
i had to change what i was saying to
myself
instead of saying i can't
i can
instead of saying i'm not
i am i can do this i can figure this out
i can learn something new
i can i can make a video
instead of saying i'm not i'm not good
enough for this i'm not an expert in
this i'm not someone who people are
going to listen to how about declaring
good things over yourself i am smart i
am confident
i am a mess but i can share my message
how about i don't
i don't have the resources for that
i don't know the right people
i don't even know how to do that
you are connected to us here at think
media
so you know how to do this
you don't need the resources you already
have it it's not about the resources
it's about the resourcefulness
and
you can figure this out you are smart
you are capable you are connected to a
company that is willing to help you for
free all you have to do is subscribe to
our youtube channels watch the videos
that are coming out learn from the
experts like sean cannell omar alticori
nolan mult tony ariola melissa caputo
heather taurus we've got a team
of creators that are here to help you on
your journey
if you want to go deeper with us we have
options to do that as well but we are
here to serve we are here to help we
want you to win
so when it comes to 2022 when it comes
to you starting your youtube channel i'm
going to be your cheerleader i'm going
to be here for you every single week
showing up on this think media podcast
to encourage you to help you to give you
the tools you need to succeed on youtube
but you got to take the step
you have to make action happen you have
to take these three things and put them
into practice in your life
so i hope that this encouraged you i
know this was fiery heather but i'm
ready for this year i am so expectant
for all that is going to happen for you
this year
we're just getting started youtube is
just getting started it's not too late
to start and you have a whole team
behind you ready for you to win
well i hope that that was an encouraging
message for you i hope that you are
going to take action and get started let
me know if you're listening on youtube
what is your youtube plan write it out
declare it let us all know so we can
root you on and be your supporter now if
you are listening over on apple i want
to encourage you to rate and review this
podcast every time we get to see your
comments uh it encourages me so much to
know that the content we're putting out
like the five part series that we just
concluded that it is helping you on your
journey thank you for the kind words
that you have over on apple and today i
want to shout out jj peller jj peller
left this comment amazingly high value
i'm obsessed jj peller i'm obsessed too
i've listened to five episodes in the
past three days so much value thank you
for sharing such amazing ideas and
insights and strategies to help me in
parentheses restart fast with youtube as
i relaunch my channel in 2022
as i relaunch my channel in 2022
joyfully jj peller well jj i hope that
this message today helped you restart
that channel i hope that you've got the
conviction to get your channel going and
to not stop this time to make every
single week a week that you are going to
put out a video that's going to help
people in the future thank you so much
for being a part of our think media
family and i cannot wait for the
upcoming content that we have for you
planned for 2022. but if you want to
continue this fire you need to make sure
you register for our free 5 day youtube
1k challenge this is going to be a
challenge that we're going to be doing
with tens of thousands of content
creators online from brand newbies to
people who have already reached a couple
hundred thousand subscribers but if you
want to get started and learn how to get
your first 1000 subscribers like what
are the steps that i should take how do
i pick my niche and how do i actually
get in front of the camera and start
pressing record what should i say in my
videos and then how do i release my
videos what should i be doing after that
we're covering all of that and so much
more during this free five-day tube 1k
challenge you can register right now and
invite a friend over at
tube1kchallenge.com thank you so much
for listening and i'll catch you in a
future episode
you